الاب والام المثاليان يكونان من الشخصيات
الدقيقه جدا يريدان كل شيء جيد وصحيح
بالنسبه ل 100% ويطبقان هذا على الابن
يفرضون عليه ان يتصرف بطريقه التي يرونها
هم مثاليه جدا ولا يتركني له المساحه
ليقول رايه او يعبر عن نفسه هذا الهوس
بالمثاليه والكمال من شانه ان يجعل
الابناء عرضه المخاطر العقليه بحسب خبراء
علم النفس وهم يقصون على انفسهم ويخافون
من الفشل فنظرا لان العديد من الاهداف
التي وضعها الاباء والامهات المثليين
للاطفال غير واقعيه تماما سرعان ما يجد
العديد من الاطفال ان الانجازات والنجاحات
تخلو تماما من المتعه ويسبب هذا السعيد
كمال ان يكون الاباء مجهودين جدا طوال
الوقت ولا يمكنهم ان يرسموا السعاده على
وجوه ابنائهم كما انهم عاجزين عن
الاستمتاع بالحياه بالتالي تكون نتيجه طفل
تعيش غير سليم نفسه
وبحسب الباحثين فان فكره الاباء المثليين
هي اكذوبه كبيره وما يحتاجه الابناء ليس
شخصا خارقا وانما اب او ام جيده ومحبه
وسعيده ايضا ويقول الباحثين ان اكتشاف
الابناء لبعض عيوب الاباء يمنحهم الثقه
للتعلم من ارتكاب الاخطاء ويوفر لهم قدوه
جيده ولهذا على الاهل مشاركه اطفالهم قصص
اخفاقاتهم ويشرح لهم كيف تعلموا من الفشل